[Music]
sarah's in dallas texas hi sarah how are
you
hi i'm great how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
i want to thank you first of all my
husband i found you a few years ago and
didn't realize how much debt we were in
um with student loans and everything and
in the past four years we've paid off a
hundred and uh 160 000 of debt and
except for our house we're completely
debt-free way to go good for you you do
why'd it go yeah it's really exciting
and with home values we have a ton of
equity in our home now so it's great
good good um so
we're at the point now so we own a small
business we have a handyman at home you
know repair home services business
for the first few years it was my
husband and then we hired a guy
no now we've got two teams with two
vehicles vehicles are both completely
100 paid off
um
but we got so busy over the last couple
years we realized we really need to hire
admin people so in the last few months
we hired you know one office manager
he's doing all the invoices all the
stuff we used to do around the clock
answering phones estimates invoices and
one person that's handling you know
marketing and promotions and our website
and all that good stuff wow good for you
yeah so it's exciting and it's growth
but it's also the first time we've
really had overhead where like you know
even if our guys are in the field
working like we're still paying them
salary to be in the office
um so it's cutting it a little closer
than normal and
we have plenty of business we have a
great reputation
um we have the work but we need to in
order to get to the next level in our
business we need to have a third team
hire two more guys get another vehicle
and then again that would add about our
projections will add about another 80 to
100 000 revenue you know to add another
team on
but our problem lies in the vehicle
um right now in the short term
cars are appreciating in this weird
market where like
supply and demand is all wonky and cars
are supposedly going up in value to
where we've been searching for months
for like a chevy express like a small
box truck or a ford transit and we just
bought one in cash two years ago for 25
000 now they're selling for 45 or 50 000
and we don't have that much cash you
know just to buy it outright
oh the car market has gone bizarre
but it is not doubled
for the same exact car it did not 25 to
40 or 50.
you were trying to you're trying to get
a better car than the last one you
bought
well no they're exact same so we bought
a ford transit like a 2018 and we bought
it right at the beginning of 2020. it
had 15 000 miles on it we've put 30 000
miles on it since then and those same
exact car if we sold it tomorrow like on
facebook marketplace or on cargurus
they're selling for 43 to 45 000.
like with the extra miles in used
condition they're selling for more so
we're either going to get that car or we
could go up to like a chevy express a
little bit bigger box truck but that was
only fine for 48 to 50.
so we could we could definitely get a
smaller car because we're looking for
you
um we have 22 000 in our emergency fund
so not all of it
this is not an emergency this is not an
emergency
exactly you can't use your emergency
fund to grow your business it's not an
emergency
very true
so you don't have the money if you don't
have the money
okay
so you don't buy the truck you don't you
don't have the crew so continue to save
just because
you need to make some money to grow your
business your business should grow with
money it
makes yeah
so you guys don't do any retained
earnings or anything like that no
savings
uh
savings like our our personal account
you mean
you have any money saved that is not
retirement accounts
oh just the 22 000 our emergency fund
and then the equity in our home so you
don't have the money to do this deal you
shouldn't even be talking about this
that's your personal emergency fund or
is this just for the business
i mean it's our personal emergency fund
yeah they don't hurt but they don't have
a business emergency fund they don't
have any money you know when it's a
small is just a small business like one
and the same yeah
so here's what's here's what's happening
okay
uh you're about to
step into the classic trap that small
business people do all the time
you're about to you've gotten so excited
about this and you built it up in your
head that you're about to step over into
stupid to expand your business
okay and you're about to go into debt to
buy a dadgum truck
to add crews and you're not even going
to break even on it for two and a half
years
no
well and the only reason we're not we're
not trying to justify it but we would
never do that with the personal vehicle
it just sits it just sits on the drive
but this is going to make us money this
would if we add another crew that's 8
200 000 revenue so we're thinking well
that is justified because we have that
is justifying yeah that's the very
definition of justifying it
okay you're rationalizing your butt all
the budget where you're rationalizing
your bottom line
you're gonna do this no matter what i
tell you
please don't do it
please i beg you
i've grown a 300 million dollar business
with cash that the business made
one year at a time for 30 years
i have not ever borrowed money i'm
sitting in a studio that cost 2 million
dollars just for the freaking studio and
i i needed the studio to broadcast but
we didn't do this until we could pay
cash for it
and that way when the freaking pandemic
hits and all revenue stops i don't go
out of business because i don't have
debt hanging around my net for an
overpriced truck please don't do this
okay please
now here's what you do need to do
i think your prices are too low
okay you haven't raised your prices at
all in the last three years have you
actually we have how much we have twice
how much um
it uh used to be you know like 60 an
hour per guy and then it was 80 and now
it's almost 95 an hour you're doing
better than i guessed i was wrong i was
wrong you're doing better than i guessed
because um
so your margin should be going up on all
this paid for stuff then
and it shouldn't be that close yeah so
what's your top line what's your gross
revenues
uh it's about 240 000
okay and what'd you net on that that you
paid taxes on
uh 140.
that's great margin
it's a great margin okay out of 140 i
want you to start saving money to buy a
used van to add the third crew
and when you have the money add the
third crew
but not until you've got it okay you
have the money
listen here's the thing the businesses
that stay open
don't run out there on the edge of thin
ice borrowing money in order to expand
expand expand as if there's no tomorrow
because there is a tomorrow and it might
have a pandemic in it
and then you get yourself in a crack and
just don't do this don't do it and you
guys you paid off 160k in four years and
that tells me you're not scared of doing
the hard work and so how quickly could
you save up 40 grand if you did that
that's 40 grand a year they did it so
you know
40 50 grand you can save in a year
based on that ratio and you can go pay
cash for this fan
um
i gotta tell you i mean i she sounds
like she's done the research on the van
i'm having a real hard time believing
that but i may have happened i may just
be that much out of touch i am aware
cars have gone up considerably on the
short term here but i was not aware you
know maybe the construction business is
completely booming out of control too
and that's running those types of
vehicles doubling the pressure on the
vans more than just normal and i'm going
to use a car can you get a cheap pickup
truck for now that'll do the job just
for right now i don't know what you need
really need to do this i don't have any
idea but i i
pay cash for whatever you're gonna do
and you know you you do not justify this
you just worked to get out of that and
then you called me trying to get back in
that what did you expect me to do
and what happens is they go well if we
got two trucks dave then we could have
200k more because we and then it was if
you got eight trucks but then you got
eight hundred thousand dollars in debt
you know starting to get started about
the potential revenues without looking
at the risk
there's this thing you don't know what
you don't know until you're there
and then you're gonna learn
please you're just adding so much risk
and they've worked so hard to get out of
this debt on their personal side all
right go back in what's all personal
debt believe me they're not loaning that
little business any money at the bank
they're loaning that woman money
she'd be signing personally
don't do this please don't do it please
don't do it please don't move you got
dave crying now it's a bad situation
don't cry no just okay just whining
there's a difference